hey youtubers it's Charlie so it looks
like they've almost found cable for
Deadpool - so I'm gonna do a breakdown
of the actor they're looking at as well
as Domino because it looks like
Mackenzie Davis might end up being
Domino so here we go
so the big news is that Kyle Chandler is
being looked at for cable they're
obviously looking at a number of
different actors but the reason Kyle
Chandler is a surprised Moseley is just
because of his look he's a really tall
person but he's just not like swole like
cable and when you're looking at cable
in the comics typically you think of
someone who is a giant that Dwarfs
Deadpool Ryan Reynolds is also a very
tall person and even with liberal use of
CG it's hard to show that disparity so I
think that's gonna be one of the
departures from the comics like we'll
see a version of cable that's very true
to the comics but it's not gonna be like
the disparity between Colossus and
Deadpool because that's typically the
way you think of cable when you think of
him in the comics you think of him as
being Colossus sized because he's
already really big and largely thanks to
the work of Rob Liefeld
like you can look here at the spider-man
picture you can see how much gear he
wears so like think about how big
spider-man is this is cables gear so the
joke is is that he's like this walking
armory so I'm expecting them to have
some fun with that idea just you know
poking a little bit of fun at cables
depiction in the comics while also doing
all the normal things that the movie
will be doing they've already said that
they're gonna be taking liberal
opportunities to make fun of superhero
sequels in general which is typically
something you see sequel movies do like
the best recent example of a movie
making fun of sequels is the end of 22
Jump Street they dedicated their whole
post-credit scene to the idea of making
fun of like a billion different sequels
to their one movie so Deadpool isn't
gonna be doing that exact thing but they
will be having a lot of fun poking fun
at sequels particularly like the latest
slate of world ending scenarios
superhero sequels like x-men apocalypse
Avengers infinity war Batman V Superman
you get the idea but let's talk about
Kyle Chandler so if you're not familiar
with the actor most people know him from
Friday Night Lights but he's been in a
bunch of movies he's primarily a
dramatic actor like he hasn't done a lot
of superhero movies but most of the
characters that he plays the thing that
he's really good at is being the
get serious character like Friday Night
Lights is a good example you have all
these crazy teenagers that are trying to
make it through high school alive win
football games so that's where most of
the drama comes from the coach is the
guy who's like I can't believe all this
that you guys are getting into we
need to get serious we have a game so
keeping in mind the tone of the first
Deadpool movie imagine an utterly
serious character coming in and trying
to kill Deadpool because he does
something that leads to some really
post-apocalyptic terrible world ending
scenario so just to back it up a little
bit if you haven't read a lot of
Deadpool or a lot of cable in the comics
when they first ran into each other
Deadpool had been hired to kill cable
and his team of new mutants that's where
cable showed up for the first time we
didn't know that he was secretly the son
of Scott Summers and Madeline Pryor
who's kind of like a clone of Jean Grey
so here's where things start to get a
little complicated but cable is a
character that's from the future he time
travels into the past to try and save
the future now they've already done that
in the x-men movies so I'm not expecting
like a copy-paste
plot element to the movie but he comes
back into the past to train this badass
team to take down this Future villain
called strife who turns out surprise
surprise is a clone of his in this big
plot with mr. sinister and apocalypse so
you can already see like there's a lot
of crossover with the big x-men
franchise but they said at least for now
deadpool is going to be a largely
self-contained franchise just because
the tone is so crazy they're like we
want deadpool to be able to be deadpool
we don't want have to shoehorn him into
a big x-men movie we just want them to
be able to do all the things that they
want to do with those movies without
having to worry about what's going on in
the x-men franchise but I would expect
you know just like with deadpool 1
having a whole bunch of x-men jokes it's
not gonna be exactly like the strife arc
from the comics but I'm expecting
liberal Easter eggs so like at the
beginning of this big arc back in the
90s cable comes back into the past to
train a badass team to fight strife but
Deadpool gets hired by another person in
the x-men universe to kill their team
then through the rest of the 90s
Deadpool goes off into his own title
they continue to butt heads Deadpool is
just used as this really badass
wisecracking assassin most people
nowadays whether they think of cable and
Deadpool they think of like a buddy cop
roadtrip flick but they didn't really
start doing that in the comics till more
recently when they were trying to make
the Deadpool character a little more
appealing to younger audiences when he
first debuted he was way more hardcore
there was way more blood
now he's used mostly for comedy but what
I'm expecting is is that the movie will
sort of take all that into account like
they will honor the first time Deadpool
met cable in the comics it'll be like
deadpool vs cable before they have to
come together at the end of the movie in
the relationship resembles the more
modern comics with cable and Deadpool so
through it although cable is still the
utterly serious character
he's very Kyle Chandler so if you're
still thinking Kyle Chandler cable and
it sounds kind of confusing to you like
you're like I don't really see him as
cable it's mostly you know mostly
because physically he doesn't look like
cable forget about that that's actually
relatively easy to do with a lot of Rob
Liefeld Dean of his costume it's
relatively easy to make Kyle Chandler
look bigger it's a lot harder to find a
really huge swole actor they can act
really well that is the problem with
Hollywood like it's really hard to find
actors that are amazing and are also
giants it's the performance that's hard
to nail so usually when they're looking
for actors for specific roles even in
the comic book movies they usually look
for amazing actors first and then for
actors that sort of kind of fit the
physical description of the role second
this is actually a good example of that
but if you guys don't know boss logic he
does a lot of fan art for really big
superhero things this is a good example
of what Kyle Chandler might look like as
cable but it's totally gonna be fine
they're shooting the movie early next
year so I would expect them to
officially confirm who is playing cable
by the end of this year at least but let
me know in the comments who do you guys
want to see play the Cable character
right now like who do you feel like is
an amazing actor and being like utterly
serious but also doing action because
it's a comic book movie there's gonna be
a ton of action and cable is like a
walking armory and he has to feel like a
threat to Deadpool like he might
actually be able to kill Deadpool you
may have also heard that Mackenzie Davis
from halt and catch fire is being looked
at for Domino that's like a whole did
for a thing so I'll talk about that in
the future Deadpool video but I feel
like she's a pretty amazing actress and
because she's not as big as say like
cable there's not as much of a stigma
attached to the character like there's
not as much baggage that comes with
casting someone for that role so I feel
like it's gonna be a lot easier to find
Domino but I am a big fan of Mackenzie
Davis so hopefully she gets the role
this is more boss logic fan art for what
she might actually look like if she gets
it which is pretty cool
so when related superhero news there was
a whole bunch of stuff that happened
recently James Gunn talked about DC
movies that he was offered but I think
it was post Christopher Nolan before Man
of Steel and even bigger than that henry
cavill just teased his black Superman
costume from the comics that he's gonna
have in Justice League so I'll do
Superman black costume Justice League
next that lettle be my next video be
sure to subscribe to get that and then
I'll do some new Punisher because they
confirmed Punisher season 1 is coming in
2017 in probably James Gunn DC fit like
the DC films that he said he was willing
to direct after that so there's a whole
bunch of comic book DC Marvel stuff
happening this week get hype so why you
guys wait for that to post you can click
here to learn more about the Man of
Steel sequel and you can click here to
learn more about the Deadpool sequel
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight